i i just started feeling more like i
have past lives i don't know what made
me feel that way if it was just
something i read and it just connected
with me i think one of my girlfriends
once said um you know there's the idea
that we have past lives and then we have
the same uh social group that we did in
past lives so if you you meet someone
and you feel connected to them right
away it's because you were connected in
a past life and that just stuck with me
for some reason and connected with me
and i loved that idea this fast forwards
to the beginning of the conversation
when i said in the past lives and of
course it's felt easy because we were
together in past lives which is what the
the akashic readers told you about us
yes because we have the same reader yes
so then you you reached out about the
akashic reading and i've just been open
to try anything and everything sure
because i get monthly forecasts from my
astrologer from bali every month she
does a birth chart little reading just a
small 10 15 minute recording of what's
to come and it was funny because i was
trying all these
different reading sessions and she told
me in one of my calls recently that this
year is going to be big for spirituality
for you so be really open to saying yes
to anything trying anything oh boy and
so if something comes up i'm like yes so
i booked a reiki session i booked the
akashic reading i just booked a tarot
card reading
and i'm just finding what connects with
me because i was never raised religious
i didn't connect with
organized religion i never understood it
i went to church when i was a little
younger tried it out and i was like
this doesn't make sense to me and just
like someone would feel that way with
spiritual with uh an akashic reading or
a past life or a different idea they're
like that doesn't make sense to me
organized religion never makes made
sense to me
but i've wanted
for this past year i've wanted to find a
deeper connection to the world around me
why am i here what is my purpose where
did i come from what is my journey after
this and i may never know the answer
solve that but why not try start digging
just like people dig into history why
shouldn't i do that the same way in my
own way
and when i had the akashic reading she
was like oh yeah of course you and
danica get along you have the same you
have a very similar past life um
experience
and she had some incredibly spot-on
things
about uh
just me as a person
um
i asked her if i would ever have
children because i've always questioned
that and she she laughed and she's like
oh yeah she's right here and my
astrologer said that you're going to
have a daughter someday it's a feminine
energy
isn't that crazy when you like talk to
them they're like oh yeah they're right
here and you're like
yeah what do they look like then what do
you mean like holy crap you know you
just want to like tap into that right
yeah so matter of fact and she
she was such a warm and kind
oh she's so sweet yeah her energy is
great
and she just had this spot on spot on
over and over but then it also made me
as soon as i got off the phone with her
i was like i'm gonna start meditating
she just said something that connected
with me i'm gonna start meditating i'm
gonna start journaling i'm gonna start
looking at crystals and so all these
things have just been little stepping
stones of trying things that i don't
know anything about
but what if something connects with me
and what if something helps me get a
better understanding of where i came
from and who i am and what my future may
look like and
purpose like
it gives me more purpose to be an even
better person and to have empathy for
people because it gives you a more
connection to the world around you yeah
and people who are going through the
same struggles with as you are but in
different ways
and when you get attacked online or a
person is mean to you in a grocery store
line or cuts you off in traffic it gives
you empathy for the person and
compassion for the person and the
struggles they're going through and
that's what spirituality has given me as
i'm on this very early new road
and where is this going to take me
business-wise where is this going to
take me and my relationships my
friendships right but it's given me
compassion for the world around me which
is has that been the main shift that
you've felt so far yeah yeah so like how
is that showing up in your life
differently now
i felt very defensive online before
where i had to always defend myself when
someone said something negative or prove
myself right or act like i knew
everything and now i can just be like
what is that i've never heard of that oh
i've never heard a word that word i
don't have that vocabulary
oh you don't like me that's okay not
everybody's gonna like me and
i hope that whatever you're struggling
with
that causes you to lash out at me i hope
you get through that
and it's just it's opened me up to
understanding that we are all human
beings learning things and figuring
things out and that's okay if we don't
know everything
and it's actually a really beautiful
thing that to know that we know very
very
very little and we have so much learning
to go yeah so that's what i've gotten
from spirituality and i can't wait to
see where it takes me in what direction
and
you know if it takes me into travel if
it takes me into different experiences
have you heard
i mean what do you think it's going to
be like because i'll
what do you think it's going to be like
the the path of spirituality yeah
um
oh man i want now i want to know what
you think it's going to be because
i think i'm going to dive deep
i think i'm going to it's going to cause
me to travel different places and do
things on my own i think i might do a
meditation retreat
um a lot of breath work
different experiences that give me
a different feeling of tapping into my
inner soul a little bit more
um
but i don't i don't know long term
well
have you ever seen those memes on social
media where by the way you're never
gonna stop i mean once you've started
now it's it's very very uncommon that
someone ever stops the ball rolling once
you get it going in the in this aspect
of growth i mean it's really about
growth but i think and i think that and
i hope i don't make anyone mad but
you know i think spirituality is is kind
of the
the word for kind of in including
everything like
yeah i feel like there's a lot of
inclusion and spirituality there's a lot
of understanding and um it's very
open-minded and i think that it's kind
of
a different path than religion organized
religion that can feel pretty regimented
and it's kind of one way and that's the
way it is and you believe these things
and so
um i that's why i call it like it's
really about growth and um
so you're gonna you're really never
gonna i don't think you'll ever stop
that so i'm what i'm gonna tell you is
not going to
deter your deter you
um because you've already seen the
beautiful benefits and there's always
beautiful benefits but here's the
problem is it ends up going you have to
go through like
um really big growth periods where it's
uh
growing pains and there's always going
to be pain with growth
and um and there is going to be
like what i like to call like an
alchemization of old energy like it has
to burn down to the ground before it can
be born again into something new and
that burning it down is really painful
and so a lot of the things that are
painful include looking at ourselves in
a much much much more
deep and meaningful and intentional way
and accountable
like that's probably the thing that's
changed the most for me in my life is
the accountability that i have for
myself how i show up my reactions um
and it's just like a never-ending
journey um but
but what i was going to say is on
instagram how they have what we thought
the spiritual journey would look like
and it's like kittens and rainbows and
it looks so great and then what the
spiritual journey is really like and it
has like someone that's super distraught
like makeup down their face and their
hair is a mess and there's like kleenex
box next to them because i've gone
through iterations of really big burning
down of certain things and
realizations of things that are going on
um because you know it really forces you
to look at the truth of what's going on
in situations to realize and and and the
truth will come through and so sometimes
it's like
and i think in a lot of situations with
a lot of people they kind of stay right
stay in the same place and don't change
a lot and don't grow so there tends to
not be these burned down fear periods
there's not these growth spurts these
pains um because nothing's changing so
it's all just kind of status quo um but
once you're on the journey it's it's
it's gonna keep going